[Music]
hey everyone it's stephanie wong
and today is a very special day because
i'm sure
you are all going to recognize who i'm
bringing on if you have seen networking
101
102 3 4 and 5 you have learned google
cloud's networking fundamentals
from our very own specialist ryan
prisble
and he's here today to discuss something
that's been top of mind lately for him
around enterprise networking in the
cloud and how that's
all changing so ryan welcome to the show
and you have been itching to talk about
this and get the word out
but before we dive in tell us a little
bit about your role and some of the
conversations that you've been having
with your customers around networking
sure thanks stephanie i definitely think
that's an interesting
topic on how the conversations are
changing uh so my role at google
some of you know from the previous
videos i and my team
are network subject matter experts for
cloud so we work with sales teams and we
spend pretty much my entire day talking
about networking either with customers
with product managers or with some of
our tech leads on the engineering side
so that's a little bit my my background
prior to google though
i think it's interesting though that um
i was a very traditional sort of network
engineering guy
right so i worked for a you know large
telco company
and i dealt with kind of the lower
layers of the stack right like i say
very traditional
sort of networking so what i'm going to
talk about today is
it's something of a functional shift for
myself in addition to the customers
which is why i thought it was
interesting because it definitely has me
thinking a little bit differently about
how we build things and how the cloud is
evolving from say
the way we were having conversations
with customers just even a few years ago
yeah and you've referred to this before
as network
versus service oriented model and that's
the mentality shift that has to happen
so why has this suddenly become so front
and center for you and your customers
yeah so this is kind of what i was
mentioning where i see the conversation
itself
changing there's there's two types of
conversations i find myself having with
customers these days
so when i talk about that
network-centric model um
what i'm really talking about is you
know think about how we've built
traditional data centers for the past
you know 20-30 years that we've been
building these things right
it's very network-centric and what i
mean by that is you know we're dealing
with
a lot of routing we're dealing with a
lot of security elements
um typically i see this with very large
enterprises
right people that have tons of
applications as an example i worked with
one customer who wanted to migrate 10
000
applications into gcp um it's a it's a
very monumental task and
one of the things that we always look at
is how can we sort of make it very easy
for the customer to migrate in and a lot
of times it's
you know we use the term forklifting
right it's sort of taking their data
center
environment and kind of replicating in
the cloud now we never want to do like
an apples-to-apples replication you know
we want to
maybe change some things and take some
advantage of some of the things that
cloud brings to the table
um but that's when i say like networking
sort of centric architectures and
network-centric conversations it's all
about that how do i manipulate routes
how do i
sort of build this infrastructure and a
lot of times
the customers don't even really because
there's either so many applications or
they don't really deal with the
application teams it's really
infrastructure engineering teams
they don't even know what's going to
come into the cloud right now the other
conversation i think we have
and what i use the term like service
centric model i typically see this with
you know customers that were born in the
cloud or you know are relatively new
they're not dealing with a whole
ton of monolithic applications on the
backside right
there their applications have been built
using microservice architectures and
we're talking a lot about services less
about networking it's not that
networking doesn't exist
it's just the focus isn't so much on
networking
more on services and how services
operate in the environment
yeah and this is something that i bring
up all the time in terms of
different concepts in the cloud and it
seems like we're moving towards this
trend of higher level of abstractions
whether we're talking about networking
or we're talking about virtualization
so you've talked about larger
enterprises with these network oriented
teams
what's the starting point for them
versus a smaller company that
might be starting already more cloud
native yeah so i think when we talk
about these
larger customers you know i mentioned
earlier like data center we use a term
like dct data center transformation
right
and this is where we're typically
working with these customers who own
their own data centers
and quite frankly you know if you're a
retailer or you're
in some other business right that is not
networking
running a data center is not your core
business okay so it's kind of like these
companies are like hey i have to be an
expert in running a data center
yet that's not my core business i am a
retailer selling a product right but
but networking and all the stuff that
goes around operating your business it's
it's such a big
aspect of the business that they're
running their own data centers
so when we're talking with those
customers a lot it's about
you know how do they operate that data
center today and how do we create
you know again not the same exact model
but how do we take a lot of those
networking constructs
and give them those same constructs in
the cloud so that they can
move a lot of these applications
one of the challenges that we have is
you know when we're moving these
applications we're trying to i don't say
minimize the amount of changes but
you could imagine if you're a a company
who's used to
you know operating a data center and
you're forced to move 10
000 applications you don't want to make
a ton of changes to things because the
more stuff you're migrating
the more things that can break and not
work and make your cloud journey
sort of more painful so when i think
about
you know how we talk about a lot of
these sort of conversations
it's really in the framework of you know
help me understand how your data center
is
operating today right when we're dealing
with more of like a cloud native company
or a company that was made
you know born in the last few years and
has really developed applications very
differently they're not dealing with
10 000 you know applications that have
been built over the 30 years
um they don't operate a data center
right um just as an example is a kind of
a funny story
i talked with a customer who they
introduced me to their network engineers
and their network engineers told me i've
never configured a router i don't really
know a whole lot about how routing works
yet these are their kind of network
engineers
but because again they're not dealing
with a lot of these antiquated older
constructs you know they just weren't
they weren't familiar with them and they
weren't as concerned about them so
the conversations again were very
different it was more about this is the
service this is this is
how the service actually operates how do
i actually build this
in the environment um and like i said we
weren't really getting into
all these complex details about creating
routing domains and overlaying very
complex security policy over that a lot
of that stuff comes from
just legacy stuff and the way customers
have thought about their data center
right and i think traditionally network
architects and engineers were the ones
who were handling things like
routing and when they were physical
things right and so
it seemed like before they were the ones
who were handling this while not having
as much visibility into what application
developers were doing
um and it kind of reminds me of how
things are starting to change
even when it comes to devops culture for
example um
there's more relationship between
developers and
operators so do you see that happening
with networking
and the application developers or is it
still uh
somewhat of a black box architects and
will it continue to be like that yeah
um i definitely think a lot of customers
still very much
like i'm going to use the term
separation of church and state right um
i work with a very large company on the
west coast and we work with
you know their entire engineering team
and
just as a sort of case in point they
don't even know what applications are
going to come into the environment so
they build everything as sort of a
hybrid cloud environment where
they they present to their developers
and application teams like
here's what services are available in
gcp but here's what services are
available in other clouds
and they leave it up to the application
teams to decide
where they want to deploy right so it
could be in gcp or it could be one of
our competitors right
and this is becoming more and more
common too right where people are
wanting to embrace a multi-cloud server
environment
so they're trying to create kind of an
apples to apples comparison between
these different clouds and the the data
center that they run on-prem so that
when an application team
comes in to run something in the cloud
they don't really care where it runs
whether it runs in their data center
on-prem
whether it runs in uh gcp or runs in one
of our competitors right they leave that
up to the application team to decide
what is the best environment for them
so in that case they are in some ways
completely isolated
and it makes it really interesting
because when we talk to them about you
know what is the future workload look
like and what you know how do you sort
of plan
the stuff one they don't even know right
and two i mean i say this kind of
loosely but they don't really care
right it's kind of like we just build
the infrastructure and we present all
these capabilities to our internal
business units and they make all the
decisions around this stuff
do you think that that's the case for
cloud two because i'm imagining an
application developer
that is working with let's say google
cloud they do have to somewhat have a
fundamental
understanding of how vpcs work and
somewhat know
the operational aspects of it or do you
still think it is
fairly segregated um again i think it
depends on the size of the organization
right the really big organizations with
you know let's say you have 500
traditional network engineers working
for you right it's still a very
segregated conversation
and then i would also say depending on
how we build the infrastructure
the developers don't always even really
even have to have a lot of knowledge
about the underlying infrastructure
right
if the team that we work with does it
the right way
right and they're automating everything
and
they're using a lot of the tools that we
give them and recommend they can
like deploy the environment very quickly
and very seamlessly and then the
developers can come along and
and everything is completely transparent
to them right they can build vms they
can do what developers want to do
right and not have to worry about all of
the
infrastructure components so again if
you kind of do it right you can have the
infrastructure team still being very
walled off
and have the development team come in
and and do their work right
but again to your point the the newer
companies that we deal with when i say
newer you know i think about
you know companies that are doing
service offerings in the cloud right
like maybe that's like their main
business
a lot of times their network engineers
are definitely a lot more attached at
the hip
at the you know with the developers and
with the services that are running
because they may be running just a
handful of services
in the cloud environment it's not like a
like i said before
an engineering team that's like we have
10 000 applications they can't
be like attached to the hip with 10 000
different developers who are working on
all this different stuff it's just
impossible so
i think a lot of your question kind of
depends on how big is the organization
and how much we use the term technical
debt right but how much how much baggage
do they have that they're trying to move
into the cloud environment
yeah and so let's let's drill in on that
a little bit because we're talking about
companies of varying sizes backgrounds
network topology sizes so how does a
path differ for a company that does have
10 000 applications and more of a
traditional networking
complex topology versus a company that
is cloud native
has a service in the cloud already and
they can
kind of get up and run more up and
running more quickly there yeah so
i think the path and i'm going to sort
of go back in history a little bit right
so
four to five years ago i would say you
know a lot of conversations were
we want to dabble with the cloud we want
to move some applications in
um nothing business critical you know i
see a lot of the big organizations that
are still trying to onboard they're
still kind of in that model right
let's let's try to rebuild as much of
the data center as we can
in the cloud okay and i use the term i
like fruit right
it's you know call it like apples to
apples or like apples to oranges right
you know an apple is round and maybe red
and an orange is round but maybe
you know orange you know we're trying to
get them to maybe go from apples to
oranges we don't want to get them to go
from like apples to cherries right i
mean that's a very different fruit it's
much smaller
completely different color uh forgive my
my high level analogy there but
hopefully that makes sense right um you
know because we want them to take some
advantages of the cloud but
asking them to make too much of a change
is just
more than some of these large
enterprises can bite off right like you
don't want to
set yourself on a path to migrate 10 000
things and then find out
you change so many things when you
migrate to cloud that half the
applications don't work they're broken
right you can create a lot of
operational challenges for yourself and
that's where our team comes in like
we're trying to really understand
while we're building networks we're
trying to understand like what are the
applications that run on top of all of
this stuff right because we don't just
build networks in a vacuum right we
build them to support applications
but we also understand you know we're
not just dealing with technology
okay like i can build all sorts of
networks in the cloud
but you've got things like operational
models okay there might be a team of
you know 500 operational engineers who
have to operate this thing every day
and if they operate a certain type of
network that's what they're used to
dealing with and if i sort of take that
network and completely change it too
much
well they got to retrain 500 people
their tools that they use for monitoring
might have to change
right so it's not just about the
technology and how we're using it but
you've got to really consider
you know the applications that we're
moving the operational models the
business structure that the customer
uses
and again this is where things get
really complex with these large
enterprises right
they're businesses they may have 30
different business units that all
operate in a very specific way
if they change things too much and and
the business units can't operate in that
same way
that can be very problematic for their
business so it's very interesting
working with these large enterprises
because it's not purely a technology
conversation right we're trying to build
the right network but we're trying to
look at all these different lenses
to build the right network for the
customer that allows them to migrate in
the cloud capitalize on some of what the
cloud
brings to them but not create so much
change
that it's going to be completely
disruptive for them and
that's where i think the conversation is
really interesting between like the
service model and the architecture model
the service model can be a very
different change
right to start thinking about i mean
think about this way if you're a network
engineer and you're dealing with
networking and routing and all of a
sudden ask you to say don't be so
concerned about that be concerned more
with
how your service is functioning they're
like well i've never thought about my
service i've never really thought
about that before right like i just
built the infrastructure and the service
teams come in and use it and i'm saying
no no no
we're gonna do a paradigm shift here
right that can be a lot for a company to
bite off so
even though i think that's the future a
lot of companies are going that way and
that's even how google runs when you
look at
google as a company we run services
right we run gmail we run search we run
youtube
while we have a very complex underlying
network
that's not what we we you know focus on
every day we focus on
the service as a service up as a service
running right
right and and this path that we're
talking about involves responsibility
both from the cloud provider and the
customer as you're saying it's a
paradigm shift for both
right so when we're talking about
building a bridge between going from
apples to
oranges what is actually being
abstracted and handled by a provider
like google cloud
in a service oriented model yeah so it's
a really good question so if
you look at a traditional networking
model and i have a bunch of different
applications that are running just as an
example
okay typically you were saying this
application is running over here and
this application is running over here
and the two need to talk together
so what is the route to get between them
and what sort of functionality what sort
of security parameter do i have to
overlay on the top of it
but generally speaking we're dealing
with sort of layer three and four
connectivity okay with with a security
bend to it at some level
when you start to talk about service
networking let me talk about one
particular product let me talk about
private service connect or psc as we
call it right
psc is designed to be what we would you
the term i would use as a service
endpoint
right so think about it as an endpoint
that you put into your network
that frontends a service and that could
be a service you're consuming from some
outside
entity it could be a service that you're
consuming from another business unit
but it abstracts a lot of things for you
and
and changes the conversation to how do i
route between here and here it's kind of
just
how do i get to the end point but once
it gets to the end point pse does a lot
of things under the covers that you
don't see it handles the routing
to that other that what we call the
service producer right which again could
be something that lives completely
outside of your organization right it
could be a third party company that
you're buying a service from
so how do you route to that company how
do you handle like overlapping ip space
right if you're
if you're a traditional network engineer
and you're looking at this you're kind
of going okay i've got this ip space
here and this ip space here and i have
to manage it
in some way or i have to control that in
between them
and i'm going to install this device
that's going to do this and again
very network-centric conversation you
introduce psc to the mix and it's like
just
route it to the endpoint and google will
manage everything else we'll manage the
routing
to somebody else in somebody else's
environment completely
will handle all of the natting and all
of that stuff for you so you don't have
to worry about it
so again it just becomes this endpoint
that sits in your network that
front ends the service and we're looking
at doing that you know even with like
google apis and google services where
you can put a psc endpoint in place
right to front-end those apis and you
can control it a little bit different
now one of the things i would say is if
you're a traditional network team and
you're like well okay
what happens when the service doesn't
work how do i troubleshoot this
you know because google is managing a
bunch of the store if you google's
managing some of the routing google's
managing some matting under the covers
you kind of lose visibility to some of
that stuff
right and if you're thinking for a very
network-centric mindset
it kind of causes this knee-jerk
reaction to say like okay
as a network engineer myself somebody
who's been in a situation of like is it
the network that's causing the problem
the network engineers are always trying
to like clear the network and say it's
not the network and you need visibility
end to end
but with something like pse and i'm not
saying pse is a bad thing but you know
once it hits that end point you kind of
lose visibility to it is it something on
the other side that's not working that
you can't see is it the service producer
that's having a problem
you know at the end of the day what
really matters is the service is down
okay but how you troubleshoot it and how
you sort of approach it
is is very different right and i i can
understand hesitation around
relinquishing control or visibility so
that you can troubleshoot and actually
find root of cause
and we'll talk more about this later
about you know some of the network
intelligence that we provide
for visibility but i do want to
highlight a point that you were making
earlier about
not needing to completely shift your
existing model
to the cloud when it doesn't make sense
and it kind of reminds me of what we
tell customers about microservice
migration like people who are moving
from
virtual machines into more of a
containerized environment
you you should actually move what makes
sense and you don't necessarily need to
do a complete decoupling or
re-architecture
are you seeing most companies using
cloud native apps to adopt
these this service-oriented model or is
there actually an
opportunity to use traditional more
hefty applications
built on complex networking models and
shift that to a service-oriented model
so it's a really good question i think
the the answer is you can
right so if you have these big
monolithic applications and we and we do
talk to customers about this right like
you can spend time to
to like re-architect the application
right the question is do you want to
right so if it's an application that you
know is going to be business critical
for the next 20 years
and you're wanting to sort of move into
more of a service-centric
model and you want to sort of break it
down into microservices so you can make
changes to small parts of the
application without trying to overhaul
the whole thing sure
it may make sense for you to do that
right but think about it from this
perspective you have a working
application
right maybe it doesn't really work with
sort of these service level constructs
it's not set up with a micro service
right um
it's it is just this big monolithic
thing that you want to move we move
those things all the time and they work
just fine
so if you're a business leader in that
company and you can migrate that
application into the cloud
you know a lot of times it's just do it
right and
don't spend the time and the resources
to like re-architect the whole thing
because a lot of these applications
they're not going to be something you're
going to use for 20 years right they're
going to change
so i again i'll go back to that term
technical debt you could move a very
large application in and it brings with
it some technical debt
you could spend a lot of time and money
trying to fix a lot of that stuff
or you can just take the approach of i
know in five years that application's
going to go away anyways
so i don't want to spend the time and
the money to you know refactor
re-architect the application
into a new sort of construct i just know
when we build the next one or whatever
that next application is for that piece
of my business maybe it's your hr
application as an example
it's going to be more cloud native in
the future right it's going to be like
software maybe we're going to go and use
software as a service from somebody else
right and this is going to be a service
that's running in the cloud and maybe
that company is going to use
psc as an example right to
basically put an endpoint into my
network that basically
means my entire hr monolithic
application that i use today
is going to go away in five years
because i'm not using software as a
service
through some other company so when you
think about that
does it really make sense to spend the
time in the effort to do it
in a lot of cases my point of view is it
doesn't right like we can make it work
in the cloud
most times so let's sort of
make it work and let's just move on and
just acknowledge that there's technical
debt there and it maybe is not the
optimal architecture for what you want
right and i think companies probably are
on the same page as you as
you know not wanting to reinvest a whole
lot of upfront capital just to change
the things that are already working
and as we know architectural changes get
new security reviews and
a lot of downstream effects right so do
you have any stories of customers
or people you've worked with that have
had to go through this process
yeah so interesting enough i uh i was
working with one customer
and one of the things people have
understood about cloud is it's a
constantly evolving model and i think
we'll talk about this
in the next segment that we're going to
do right it's not like your traditional
data center right things change much
faster in the cloud
and we'll talk about that of the why but
a lot of enterprises
to change their architecture i actually
had a very senior architect
i mean kind of yelling at me on the
phone and kind of saying like it's great
that google can shift on the fly like
that
but every time we make architectural
changes they have to go through security
reviews there's all of this red tape
that has to be done
so when we think about you know with
this particular customer i was like you
know this is the way the architecture
will look today
in six months or 12 months there's all
these other features are going to come
down the pipe and this is how i would
change it in the future and that's where
it was creating this really kind of
tough rub to say yeah but for me to
implement those changes it's going to
take me six to 12 months because i have
to have security reviews i have to have
architecture reviews
so there was all this red tape right
that sort of comes around with
making these changes to customers so
while we're always kind of saying like
the cloud is constantly evolving you
want to constantly be changing we also
have to be cognizant that
you know google can change on a dime
this is the way google was built
okay but not all enterprises can do that
and that's okay
i think we as a company just have to be
cognizant that not everybody operates at
google
um and i say it's kind of a funny story
because literally they were yelling at
me saying i have to go back to
enterprise 101 school because that's not
how enterprises work right
right right and and i do want to dig
into this a lot more ryan but
we're going to save some of this for the
next segment as you mentioned
um and i want to dive a little bit more
into that
operational shift and what google cloud
specifically is doing
to build a bridge to get people to have
a stepping stone into a service oriented
model
so ryan thank you so much for joining
today and for everybody else
stay tuned we're going to come out with
another episode shortly yep thanks for
having me stephanie
[Music]
you